what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and as we talked about yesterday it
looked like the final castings of
Superman Lois Lane and Lex Luthor were
upon us for the upcoming Superman movie
from James Gunn Superman Legacy and as
it turns out the reports were right at
least partially right Superman and Lois
Lane have been cast for Superman Legacy
this is official James Gunn even
confirmed this himself on Twitter we do
not have an official casting for Lex
Luthor yet at least not publicly James
Gunn might have already cast him but we
do have an update on one more actor who
could possibly be in the running to play
him now this report is being ran on
every website variety deadline but James
Gunn responded on Twitter to a report
from The Hollywood Reporter I'm not sure
if they were the first to report it but
since James Gunn responded to them on
Twitter we're gonna go over the report
from them and we'll dive right into it
the headline reads Superman Legacy finds
leads with David cornswett and Rachel
Brosnahan now we knew both of these
actors were in the running for these
roles and it is in fact David cornswett
who got the role which was reported
yesterday however also yesterday
insiders reported that it looked like it
was going to be Emma Mackey however
today it is different it is not imamaki
it is Rachel Brosnahan now she was one
of the actresses who had been reported
to have read in person done those
in-person test screenings for the raw so
we knew she was in the running and it
sounds like until today it was pretty
much a tie between Emma Maki and Rachel
and ultimately it looks like DC went
with Rachel and like I said James Gunn
did confirm this in a tweet in a
response to this report he said this on
Twitter accurate they are not only both
incredible actors but also wonderful
people plain and simple we love it we
get a confirmation from James Gunn he
states that this article that we're
going over right now from The Hollywood
Reporter stating that David cornswith
and Rachel Brosnahan have been cast as
Superman and Lois Lane is accurate so
there it is and I personally think David
Corn sweat had the best look for
superman but right away go ahead and let
us know your initial thoughts about the
casting for Lois Lane and Superman in
the comments down below now what's
interesting is that Nicholas Holt has
now lost out on two other superhero
roles he played beast in the X-Men films
but for DC he auditioned for Batman
didn't get that role and now they passed
on him for Superman however it looks
like he is one of the top contenders to
possibly play Lex Luthor him along with
the Skarsgard Brothers Alexander
Skarsgard and Bill Skarsgard seem to be
right now the top three picks of who DC
James Gunn wants to play Lex Luthor but
as of right now we officially have our
Superman and our Lois Lane David Corn
sweat and Rachel Brosnahan please let us
know your thoughts about these casting
choices in the comments down below do
you like do you not like them why or why
not and also let us know who your Top
Choice is for Lex Luthor don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment this
enters you in our giveaway for a chance
to win a PS5 and Xbox series X some DC
items and some Marvel Legends items as
well the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month only a few days left now you can
check out our patreon our Discord server
and our website down below and of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf wolf
English